[Music]
every now and then one comes along and
you just know they have it in them to be
sober I used to smile this last shot I
had high hopes about man that I could be
no word from your dad can't say no these
days thank that remember Hillary what
you have a late darling we're just
chatting about Christmas unfortunately
our tables full crown I'll be clean I
want to live a life you can't do it on
your own the second time around
[Music]
excuse me do not use cat this is Bob
came to you for a reason
Bob it's what he wants you to call it in
the past I've screwed up every
opportunity up and give it you're doing
great James you you can't take on too
much too far I'm ready standing by your
side till Catholic loser
yo cake niolani give it a try help Bob
and I both shown me what life could be
like on the other side like step organs
my
I wanted to apologize for everything
who wanted me to apologize
everyone gets a second chance luckily
for me I had a very important companion
to help with my second chance don't look
at me like that
par-5 dial on quickest route no freeways
computer do you hear me hello mr. booth
I've just taken away you